Đầu đã tổ chức lẽ kỳ nhẹ mẹ cùng ngoài lần tu bệnh bị bà y ở tổ đồ điều đ而已
và các bạn đậm dựa đánh và điều sĩnh quy mô lớn,
sự kỳ đánh giá là thế hiện những bước tiến Trung hiện đại hả quân sự và bảo tổn dí sản phân và khu gia.
Lẽ giờ bình năm nay nhấn mạnh, nâng lần tự chủ nê căng ra tăng quận đội trong những vật có phòng,
khi nhiều loại bố khí và phương tiện,
giá trong nước thích kế chế tạo được dưới thiệu chức không trúng.
Các đơn vị tham gia để từ nhiều cuộc chiến cảm ơn.
cùng với màn chính giễn của không còn nền độ và cái tí mực bố tốt đặc trưng.
Một đêm nhấn đăng chú ý là họ đống tương vình trên 6 cình Đò,
chính giết phối hợp bà quan trùng trên khai tình năm 2018.
Lần đầu tiên, sẽ bà khai hạn nhẹi giữa nội tự tích kế,
chăm biệt và đà sạm sát chính trường.
Công các khẩy thống tên lượng như nặp, Ramos và Acast được chính giễn.
Bữa lẽ còn bố sử tham dự của chụi tịch Ui Ban Chua Ursula von the Land
và chụi tịch Ui Đông Chua O' Antonio Khustan,
và nánh quan hiện ngày càng xong sát dẫn độ và li mình cho ông.